hello everyone and welcome to another
super enjoyable game from the chesapeal
masters knockouts this is from the
second day if you guys remember ding won
the first day uh prague wanted the
second day and then they played the thai
breaks for ding one in uh in a blitz
playoff but this is game three of the
rapids of the second day so uh prague
won the won the second game and now uh
dink has the white pieces and he uh
tries to bounce back it's a completely
uh crazy game you guys will uh enjoy it
uh prague gives up um his queen for
three pieces and uh well uh
so so many things can happen but it is
just super complicated so let's just
dive straight into it and it's a very
long game so be prepared for that over
100 moves so ding has the white pieces
and he opens with c4 he goes for the
english opening with e5 knight to c3
knight to f6 knight to f3 and knight to
c6 we have the four knights of the
english uh e4 uh we have bishop to b4
and now pawn to d3 defending the e4 pawn
d6 we have h3 and here prague castles we
have bishop to 82 and now uh pawn to a6
uh ding already had this position in
march this year you know ding had to
play a whole lot of games to be able to
qualify for the candidates tournament
this is one of the games he played
against lee uh but in that game lee
played bishop back to c5 here prague
plays a6 we have castles and now there
is a game where bishop to c5 was played
here prague plays h6 and it is now as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game so prague just won a game uh in in
the previous one uh and now he has a
very very solid setup uh it's updating
to prove that he can push for more than
a draw so bishop to e3 uh rook to e8 and
now pawn to a3 challenging the bishop
asking do you want to capture or move
the bishop back with bishop to c5 uh
offering a trade of bishops and now pawn
to b4 being expands on the queen side
attacking the bishop hoping that of
course he will capture on e3 then he can
play f captures and e3 gain more
presence in the center and get a
semi-open f5 for his rook but here
bishop back to a7 by prague we have uh
queen to d2 and now knight to d4 yeah
putting pressure on the light square
bishop here so bishop back to d1 just
keeping the the tension the bishops
remain on the board knight captures on
f3 bishop captures and now bishop to e6
prague develops the other bishop now
dean captures an a7 with bishop captures
rook captures and now bishop back to e2
preparing the uh push of the f pawn so
here uh prague says all right you've got
some nice expansion here on the queen
side but other than that you the
position is pretty equal so i'm just
gonna uh bust open the queen side so a5
ding declines this he keeps it closed we
have b5 and now rook back to a8 the rook
could be a bit vulnerable here on a7 and
you know prone to all sorts of discovery
so just a rook back to a8 and now ding
strikes uh in the center with f4 uh we
have c6 king to h2 and now bishop back
to d7
a4 and now rook to c8 we have uh rook to
f2 here dean could also grab
uh
more more presence in the center with
the d4 and it's the the engine's
favorite idea uh but he goes for the
doubling of the rooks and the files so
rook to f2 preparing rook a to f1 queen
to b6 now uh moving the queen with tempo
and rook to f1 we have queen to d4 now
uh preparing to strike in the center
with with the d5 and we have bishop back
to d1 uh d5 now uh e capture sunday 5c
captures and now comes knight to e2
attacking the queen and this is where
things get really interesting prague
plays knight to e4 now attacks the queen
and also the rook on f2 so we either
have a queen trade let's say knight
captures tonight captures here rook
captures here pawn captures here which
would uh kind of get us a sort of an
equally sure end game maybe c captures
on d5 f5 but instead uh we have queen to
c2 moving the queen still pro queen on
d4 is under attack uh but uh prague does
not uh move it there's uh there's really
no good square to move it uh so the best
thing to do is just to give it up like
prague did so the queen captures an f2
rook captures an f2 in the knight
captures on f2 so he gives up the queen
but he grabs uh
he grabs the two rooks uh and then now
knight the c3 attacking the knight and
the pawn on d5 so if the knight just
moves we grab the pawn on d5 we have a
pawn storm here already uh it's not
going to be easy for prague to defend
this so he has to move the knight with
tempo knight captures on d1 and now of
course if queen captures on d1 we're
just gonna capture on c4 captures
captures uh all these good okay we're
not going to be able to capture a second
time because if let's say knight
captures uh or better yet queen captures
we can play d captures on c4 now this um
capture isn't all that all that
impressive uh because black would have
to move the bishop the bishop would be
hanging so we would not have the time to
capture on c4 for the moment but it is
it is playable uh however here ding
plays knight captures on the e5 he keeps
the knight alive for the moment and
wants to play knight to b6 to attack the
rook and the bishop now we have bishop
to e6 now putting pressure on the knight
so hoping for a queen capture sun e1 now
but knight to b6 attacking the rook and
here now that knight moved away from the
control of the e3 square prague plays
knight the e3 attacks the queen queen to
f2 and now e captures on f4 now prague
even sacrifices the exchange uh so
knight captures in c8 we have rook
captures on c8 and now queen captures an
f4 and now this is the position that uh
is on the board it's rook bishop and the
knight against the queen with ding still
having the possibility of creating some
sort of a pawn storm here but it's uh
it's uh it's it's easy for prague to
create a blockade here even uh in a
rapid game with a little time on the
clock he plays knight to c2 uh we have
queen to e4 now preparing to push the
pawn the knight will be under attack but
just b6 it's not a problem uh queen to
b7 attacking the b6 pawn and not knight
to b for progress says all right uh you
can capture b6 and a5 i'm gonna capture
uh d3 and c4 but the ding will still
have the two connected pass pawns here
on the queen side so here are queen
captures knight captures queen captures
and the bishop captures on c4 now it's
queen and the two connected past pawns
against two pieces in the rook so can
now probably hold this we have queen to
c3
attacking everything here if the bishop
moves the rook will fall now comes g6 uh
and here we have a5 and this is not the
most precise way to play this so we're
queen to d4
is the correct move here but it's not
easy to
understand why the point is we have to
move the queen away from the c3 square
and now we can start pushing our pawns
let's say black makes a move we're gonna
push b6 and there's not much for black
to do here if bishop to a6 guarding this
square we just push the pawn to b7 and
now the bishop is uh well
bishop captures we don't capture the
knight we actually go for queen d7 and
now after let's say 95 guarding the
bishop here
we can just play queen captures on f7
and then the position falls apart or if
you play knight to e5 guarding the f7
pawn then of course we capture the
bishop so nothing is really good good
for black here so here uh it would make
sense to play queen to d4 but it's a
rapid game and i mean the position is
completely crazy uh ding played a5 which
is also uh which is also winning but uh
it's not winning if prague finds one
specific move so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this idea for
prague while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on finding the only
move that saves the game for prague and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show the move is rook to c5 that's
that's the good stuff and now there is
no way for ding to push this for a win
that ding played b6 but now bishop to a6
guarding the b7 square and everything is
guarded the bishop covers the knight
knight covers the rook and you also have
to be careful otherwise you're going to
lose these pawns and then you will be
the one who's in trouble so queen d4 we
have rooked the seat you now going after
the g2 pawn we might be even able to
attack it queen to e4 and now rook back
to c8 so just keeping everything in
order you don't want to allow any any
checks here we have b7 and now rook to
b8 queen to c6 now attacking the bishop
and now knight to b4 you don't want to
capture the bishop uh the pawn with the
bishop if you capture here then queen b5
and you have trouble uh trouble here the
knight is attacked once you move the
knight a6 is coming and then
white will will win this in the end so
instead after queen to c6 knight to b4
we have queen to c1 and now pawn to h5
we have g4 now ding can no longer put
any pressure on the queen side he now
has to create some trouble on the king
side if he wants to get some winning
chances here so h captures on g4 and now
h4 he wants to open up the king side
rook captures on b7 and now pawn to h5
we have king to h7 and queen to g5
uh rook to b5 now attacking the queen
forcing the the capture h captures and
g6 f captures and now queen to e7 check
so ding had to give up more material uh
to be able to start checking the black
king and now prague has to be very
careful if he allows um
the the check to connect and he loses
one of the pieces it's all over luckily
for for prague all of his pieces are
defending each other rook defends the
knight knight defense the bishop bishop
defends the rook so it's a fine
structure you want to really remember
you know if you're playing a blitz game
you only have three
seconds on the clock you know with maybe
one second increment you know that as
long as your pieces are set up like this
they are defending each other so a very
nice combo here so king to h6 we have
queen fa to check king to h7 queen to f7
check we have a repetition of moose here
uh queen of fate czech king the g5 queen
e7 check and the now king to f5 we have
queen f7 king the g5 queen e7 and now
king to f4 so now it seems that it's
prague the one who's attacking his king
pawn and well once those pieces come
into game into the game it could be very
nasty for for ding's king
luckily dink can just continue checking
forever queen to f6 check king e3 and
now king the g3 giving prague the move
so is there something prop can do here
he starts with g5 the pawn is nicely
defended here now comes king captures on
g4 and king to d3 he will still pick up
this pawn at some point but he wants to
make uh
uh
make it a a good one because if you just
for example capture here on f5 there's
queen to b6 check and you've just
blundered your rook so you can't do that
so king to d3 it's important to move the
king first queen f1 check we have king
to c3 now uh queen to e1 with chuck king
to b2 we have queen to d2 with check
knight to c2 blocking
and now queen to d6 again asking do you
maybe want to capture the pawn here but
that
could also be very tricky you don't
really lose
anything because after queen to b6 check
rugby five and uh queen captures on a6
it's still it's still a drawn end game
uh you you can't really lose this with
black so uh but it's still important for
prague to try and win this knight to b4
that we have queen to d2 with checking
to b3 queen to d1 with czech king to c3
queenie one check king to d4 now queen
to f2 with chuck king to c4 queen to e2
with czech king to c5 and now he allows
the capture of the g pawn so he can
finally capture the a pawn so king g5
rook captures on a5 and now can the
pieces organize themselves uh to go
after the white king
well we'll see queen e3 check king to c6
king to h6 sorry king to h6 and now rook
to d5 so now probably will try to get
those pieces closer to the white king
queen to c3 check king to b5 we have
queen to c7 and not knight to c6 we have
queen to h2 and now king to c5 uh queen
to f2 with check knights the d4 so
getting
getting closer and closer we have queen
to a2 attacking the bishop uh now comes
rook d6 check king g5 and rook to e6 now
uh everything nicely and nicely defended
queen to a5 with check with king the c4
queen a4 check king to d5 and now queen
to d7 with check king to e4 and now
queen to h7 with check it's hard for the
black king to find shelter with the with
the queen on the open board so king to
e3 and now queen the a7 pinning the
knight uh putting pressure on the bishop
so okay you have a move is there a move
that you can make so bishop to d3 we add
more pressure to the position so king to
g4 we have rook to e5 and now kink the
h4 it doesn't seem like there's uh
there's a way to increase the pressure
here you can't move the king closer as
the knight would hang so bishop e2 we
have queen to a3 with chuck king the e4
now comes queen b4 again pinning the
knight uh we don't want to allow any
checks that could be uh very bad for
ding's king so rook to f5 king to g3 now
comes qui rook to f3 check king to h4
rook to f5 and now king back to g3 king
to e3 and now ding again checks queen e7
check king to d3 queen to a3 with check
and king to c4 we have queen a2 check
king c5 queen to a7 with check king to
d5 queen eight check with king e5 and
queen to b8 with check so ding is just
hoping uh for for a 50 move rule to kick
in or for prague to get bored of moving
the king king to e4 queen to a8 with
czech rook d5 and king to f2 we have
bishop to g4 queen to b7 still keeping
the rook pinned bishop to e6 and now
queen to a8 we reach move 100 bishop to
d7 queen b7 bishop to c6
and now queen to be one with check king
e5 queen to b8 with chuck king to e4 now
queen bee one sure king e5 queen b8
check king e4 and queen to be one check
he was in this position on move 106 that
ding and prague
agreed to a draw as there is no way to
make progress for for either side so
really a a truly a remarkable game uh
ding pushed uh for everything he wanted
to bonds back in the match as prague won
the one game two he really tried to win
game three here uh but he missed that
one chance uh where he played that uh
a5 move uh it's really crazy because if
if prague doesn't find rook to c5 then
ding is winning but luckily uh prague
was able to find it
and hopefully all of you did as you you
were pausing the video uh so really
really
remarkable stuff truly uh
i can't imagine how how difficult it was
to play this game for for both of them
it's uh you know and you know even the
slightest mistake will get severely
punished so here uh it was just uh
brilliant display by by both of them uh
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you were able to
keep up with all of the 106 moves i
would like to wish a very happy birthday
to addis rohlasan and i would like to
thank abolishing.cat first elden lord
nagarjuna ponogoti and congrats harry
three grads for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world uh so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day